another retailer in the valley expected
to close soon steinmart
it's filed for bankruptcy plans to close
almost all of its 300 locations across
the u.s
and there are three here in town sasha
loftis spoke to customers
about this latest closure this location
here is one of three across the valley
now the chain announced today that most
if not
all of its stores will shutter amid this
bankruptcy announcement
if you look behind me you can see this
particular store has signs on the front
that say
all sales final now steinmart is the
latest of many nationwide chains to file
for bankruptcy amid the coronavirus
pandemic
with a spokesperson citing quote
significant financial distress
the retailer said today that it has
launched a store closing and liquidation
process
with a going out of business sales
starting as early as friday
we spoke with some shoppers outside this
steinmart today
who say they're really sad to hear about
this i always come up here to
stone mark every chance i get and i
really
like the store you know i like the
quality i like the prices
you know it's just something that you
know everything is closing up
you know it's it's a it's a sad thing
steinhardt anticipates stores to close
by the fourth quarter of 2020. it has
about 280 stores across the nation
with around 9 000 employees now no word
on what this specifically means for the
locations here in the valley
as the chain did say that closing dates
and sale dates
of course depend on particular locations
for now reporting in the northwest
valley sasha loftis
8 news now